MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY, WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND YOUR
EXPERTISE.
>> THE TALIBAN DECLARING VICTORY
OVER EVERY PROVINCE IN
AFGHANISTAN.
STILL, RESISTANCE FIGHTERS SAY
THEY ARE STILL HOLDING ONTO
STRATEGIC POSITIONS.
LET’S BRING IN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JOE JONES, EARNED A
PURPLE HEART FOR HIS SERVICE IN
AFGHANISTAN WHERE HE SEVERELY
DAMAGED HIS RIGHT ARM AND BOTH
WRISTS AND ALSO A HOST OF THE
NEW FOX NATION STREAMING SPECIAL
THE LONGEST WAR AVAILABLE RIGHT
NOW.
YOU AND I TALKED OFTEN ABOUT
MATTERS LIKE THIS AND YOU HAVE
BEEN VERY OUTSPOKEN AND
THANK YOU FIRST FOR YOUR SERVICE
SERVICE.
I WENT TO GET REACTION JUST
HEARING NOW ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
WE MIGHT HAVE TO GO BACK.
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
JENNIFER GRIFFIN WAS
INTERVIEWING THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS SAYING IT IS TOO
SOON TO TELL WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WILL BE A RECONSTITUTION
OF AL QAEDA AND HAVE TO GO BACK
BUT NOW WE HAVE
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM TALKING
TO BBC WEIGHING IN, WANT YOU TO
LISTEN TO WHAT HE IS SAID AND
GET YOUR REACTION.
SORRY ABOUT THAT, GOING TO READ
YOU A QUOTE JUST DROP THAT ON
THE PROMPTER WHICH WE DON’T HAVE
JUST YET BUT ESSENTIALLY SAYING
WE WILL BE GOING BACK INTO
AFGHANISTAN AS WE WENT BACK INTO
IRAQ AND SYRIA AND SAYS WE WILL
HAVE TO BECAUSE THE THREAT WILL
BE SO LARGE IT COULD BE A
CAULDRON FOR RADICAL ISLAMIC
BEHAVIOR.
HERE THOUGHTS?
>> IF YOU READ THE ROOM, JUST
LOOK AT THAT INTERVIEW WITH
JENNIFER GRIFFIN.
THERE WAS NO CONFIDENCE
WHATSOEVER THAT WE ARE SAFER OR
WON’T HAVE TO DO THIS.
THAT DOESN’T MEAN DEFINITIVELY
WE WILL HAVE TO FIGHT THEM AGAIN
BUT I’VE SPOKEN TO RETIRED
FOUR-STAR GENERALS, ACTIVE TWO
AND THREE STAR GENERALS AND
EVERYONE SAID IT WAS A NICE TO
HAVE, NOT NEED TO HAVE ALL FEEL
LIKE THE THREAT IS STILL THERE
LIKE IT WAS BEFORE WE GOT THERE
AND HOPEFULLY STARTING TO TAKE
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY AND
UNDERSTAND THEIR OWN RULES AND
THAT BUT I THINK LINDSEY GRAHAM
WAS ON TV ADVOCATING FOR US, THE
COALITION FORCE IN NORTHERN
AFGHANISTAN AND I GUESS NOW
THEY’VE BEEN DEFEATED SO I DON’T
KNOW THAT HE UNDERSTOOD REALLY
WHAT HE WAS TRYING TO GET US TO
DO.
AT LEAST LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS BEEN
HONEST.
HE SAID ALL ALONG FOREVER THAT
HE WANTS TO KEEP TROOPS THERE.
AT LEAST THAT’S HONEST AND I
DON’T THINK OTHER POLITICIANS
HAVE BEEN QUITE AS BLATANT ABOUT
IT BUT I THINK ARGENT GOVERNMENT
HAS NOT DONE A GOOD JOB AND THAT
IS AS LONG AS THEY CAN FUND THE
WAR EVERY TWO YEARS, THEY
HAVEN’T FELT THE NEED TO AND I
THINK IT’S OUR TURN IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO ASK BIGGER
QUESTIONS AND TO GET BIGGER
ANSWERS WE UNDERSTAND WHY WE WOU
BEFORE WE GO AGAIN.
>> Griff: ARE WE SAFER AFTER
THIS WITHDRAWAL?
>> IS THERE JUST AS MUCH OF A
THREAT IF NOT A MORE EMPOWERED
THREAT?
ABSOLUTELY.
THEY’VE REALLY EMBOLDEN THE
TALIBAN BY GOING AND RECRUITING
YOU ROMANTICIZE ON THE IDEA THAT
A LOT OF THEM COME FROM PAKISTAN
SO THE IDEA OF RADICAL ISLAM IS
MORE THAN IT’S EVER BEEN.
THE THING THAT IS DIFFERENT IS
OUR DEFENSES HERE AT HOME, THE
WAY WE LOOK AT THREATS AND
SURVEY THINGS IN THE WAY WE LOOK
AT WHO COMES INTO OUR COUNTRY
WERE SUPPOSED TO.
THE TOP-SECRET CLEARANCE RAN IN
ON THINGS THAT HAVE ALREADY
HAPPENED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE SIR.